the christmas market is a german
tradition this one will open in cologne
on monday well that's the idea
across europe plans are being ripped up
by the resurgence of covid and here in
germany there's a sense of unease
i think people are frustrated that
nothing is happening i think we really
have to start making decisions and
and we need a government
across the country covet is back with
more new infections than ever health
officials say christmas could be
terrible
around two-thirds of the german
population is fully vaccinated that's
comparable to the uk but at this
vaccination center we were told that
rate was too low and the rollout of
booster jabs had been too slow we should
have done this earlier already we knew
that and the virologists told the
politicians so uh by august already so
the recommendation was in august or to
uh to have the third vaccination done
but unfortunately we are only starting
now to to increase the number of the
booster vaccination and hopefully it's
not too late yeah the german government
is tightening lockdown rules more and
more places will require a vaccine
passport across europe unvaccinated
citizens are being targeted and
stigmatized it's of course their choice
we can't force them but
i just find there's a rather question
also solidarity for people who don't
want to get to vaccine can't go to
restaurants and all kinds of stuff
there's like they themselves see
themselves as like second-class people
now the coveted resurgence is worst in
germany's east but its effect is
spreading fast at this hospital they are
stealing themselves
this ventilator equipment was bought by
the hospital last year when the pandemic
was at its height it's now being readied
again for a fourth wave and staff here
think that could be similarly
devastating
the doctors in the intensive care unit
fear another debilitating winter i'm
extremely worried
we got the the three waves before where
we had a lot of copper paint to treat
and a lot of them died
and now we are running straight ahead to
the fourth wave
the incidents are rising high
maybe it's also calm in the next days or
next week
but i'm sure
the wave will rise up and the wave will
hit us very hard
germany's hospitals are beginning to
fill again
this country this continent
is infected with nervousness adam
parsons sky news cologne